- Within three seconds
of that happening
my phone was exploding
in my pocket.
- It was Belichick.
You know that voice.
And he goes, "Steven—"
- "Hi, Steven."
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- This is the sign of the end
and the birth
of a new blood king.
♪♪♪
I don't wanna do the show.
I don't wanna do it.
- Let's do it, baby!
- No.
Cuz it—everyone's—
- Saints are alive!
Let's go, Saints.
- That's where we are.
But that wasn't
the biggest news.
The biggest news of the weekend
was about referees.
- Oh!
- We're not talkin' about
Sarah Thomas
is the first female in the playoffs.
We're talkin' about
this moment—
3:48 in the fourth quarter.
Patrick Mahomes is gonna
take this snap.
You were focused on Tyreek Hill.
- I was.
I was total fanboy right here.
- And then, all of a sudden,
you're in another stratosphere.
- Man!
[Laughing]
- Oh my God!
- Look at that
balance in the pocket.
- Ohhh.
- Stay on the back foot.
- Dude, this is the first time
you've danced well in your life.
- How dare you say that, Lefkoe.
- Oh, nature!
Oh my gosh.
- Thank you, graphics department.
That was great.
- What does it feel like
to be a meme?
- I, I mean,
I don't even know what to say.
All I can say is,
literally right there
I was becoming a fanboy.
I was off the white.
But of course it's my fault.
I should've been farther
off the white.
And I've been on sidelines,
like, my whole life
and that's never happened.
- You've never been hit
by a referee—
- Or, like, a coach running down?
- Never. Never. And I was—
I'm not gonna—
- Did you—cuz it looked
like you were angry.
Did you apologize?
- I was literally apologizing
as I was skipping backwards.
- "I'm sorry, I'm sorry."
- Yeah, as I went, "Oh, my bad!
I'm sorry, I'm sorry!"
I literally did that.
And then, you know,
I continued to apologize.
And then it went
into the next play, and I—
- Did he, did he go,
"Oh, don't worry about it.
It's totally fine"?
- Totally not.
He was pissed off, and—
- How many curses?
- Uh, he—no. So then, yeah.
I think he might've said like
"Get the eff
out of the way," right?
- Yeah.
- And then the next play
I'm continuing to apologize.
And I go,
"Man, I'm really sorry.
I'm a dumbass."
And he looked at me and he goes,
"At least you know it."
- Damn.
- And then he lined over
and went back to business.
But other refs on the field—
- Did you—
- Knew it was me
and they were like, chuckling.
- That's such a good burn.
- Damn, that was bad.
- He set that up so well.
- Damn.
I knew I was in trouble, Lefkoe,
cuz I swear to you
within three seconds
of that happening
my phone was exploding
in my pocket.
And I was like, "Oh, no."
- It was probably my tweets.
- Everybody saw it, yeah.
- It was amazing.
- Yeah, great, great.
One of my favorite moments
in divisional playoff history.
Really great.
- Yeah, well, you know what else
is amazing?
[Laughing]
Oh, there was a game at 4:40 on
Sunday that was quite enjoyable!
- I missed it.
I was repotting orchids.
- Mr. Drew Brees Hater,
right here!
How many yards did he throw
for in the game?
300. 300.
- I honestly don't know.
- Don't worry,
I'll answer for you.
OK, here's the first tweet.
- Hold on.
So, I wanna say something.
I have not looked at my mentions
since the game.
I have avoided them completely.
So I only imagine what people
were saying to me.
- All right. Well, this is
an intelligent one
cuz this is Ted, M.D., OK?
- Oh, it's a doctor.
- Oh, yes. He's a doctor.
And he wrote—
That's perfect!
Way to go, Ted, M.D.
Did they teach you that—
- Hold on, hold on.
That phrase.
- Yes.
- "You s--t-talking
Philly rat."
- Right.
- I felt that through the screen
you know what I mean?
- Yeah, you should. Right.
- That one, damn.
- That was hard-hitting, right.
All right.
- And it's a doctor!
- Here's another creative name,
50 Shades of Bray.
OK, I like this.
[Laughing]
- The best part is, is that he
totally went to thesaurus.com
and looked up "exuberance,"
but then ended it
with "Suck it."
- Yes.
- Because really, the first
two sentences—
- Were good.
- And then it equals "Suck it."
- Yeah, that was pretty good.
Way to go.
- Thanks, Braley.
- And then we got ol' tweet
No. 3 with just the ol'—
- Oh, wow.
- "Oh, hey, up yours."
What the hell's his name again?
- Mr. Bean.
- Mr. Bean, right.
Yes, Mr. Bean goin' by, goin',
"Hey, Adam Lefkoe.
My name's Drew Brees
and, uh, eat that."
- I'm just gonna be honest.
- Yes.
- We are having our
"Simms & Lefkoe" show down
in Atlanta at Dantanna's.
E-mail simmsandlefkoe@gmail.com
if you'd like to be
there Thursday at 6:00.
- Saints fans are welcome!
- That's what I'm worried about.
- Yeah!
- I need the real
"Simms & Lefkoe"
fans to get in there
because I'm just worried it's
gonna be a bunch of Mr. Beans
that are Saints fans
for the entire show.
- Yeah, you might have that.
Sorry.
- I'm really nervous.
- Yeah, that's all right.
Hey, it was a good season,
though. No joke.
Philly—
- For the Eagles.
- Yeah, for what they did.
- No joke?
- No joke.
I'm not even messing around.
A Super Bowl team
to basically fall off the earth
midway through the year.
- Yes.
- And usually when
a Super Bowl team falls off
like that, they go
"Eh, OK, we won the Super Bowl
last year.
We'll see you next year."
- Yeah.
- The rally back, and—
- I agree.
- Really become, again
one of the better
teams in football
and have a chance
to win that game.
So props to your Eagles.
I'll give you that much.
- You just witnessed one of
the first genuine moments
in "Simms & Lefkoe" history.
- All right, let's go.
Jamal Adams,
and I'm on "Simms & Lefkoe."
My two guys.
- All right.
We have Steven Jackson.
We don't wanna waste
any more time.
Just go.
- All right, so here we go.
You got two teams. You played
two out of the four teams.
You played the Rams,
the Patriots.
We'll get to the Patriots
in a second.
But first of all,
do you root for the Rams?
Like, are you a Rams fan
because of your time there?
- Yeahhh.
- That's a no.
- That was a big breath.
- That was a lean back—
- You saw that body language?
- Yeah, I did.
That was bad body language.
- It is bad, I know.
- But you're one of the all-time
greats in Rams history.
It's you, Dickerson,
and Gurley and Faulk.
- Well, so wait.
That's where I wanna go.
- Right.
- But of course, he's gonna ask
my question now, too
is, do you—
all right.
So, first of all,
do you root for the Rams?
Just start there.
- I do.
But I—
it's bittersweet, right?
- Yeah?
- It's like, you give them
almost a decade, nine years
you give them
everything you have.
Never better than 8-8.
- Right.
- Nine seasons
I had six coaches—
- Right.
- Counting interim coaches.
I had six coaches—
- Right.
- Counting interim coaches.
- Yes.
- So all I know is turnover.
- Yeah.
- And now to see the success
of this group.
- Before you is the Greatest
Show on Turf.
- Yeah.
- After you is Sean McVay
and this offensive explosion.
- Right.
- In-between—
- Yeah, I'm just the meat.
- Yeah.
Well, I know.
So, so, I do.
I mean, you're one of the great
running backs of all time.
You're 18th on the all-time
rushing list.
- Wild.
- Do you feel like
you're almost,
like, the forgotten man
not only as a whole,
but for the Rams?
Like, I feel like people
just go
"Marshall Faulk" and "Todd Gurley."
And they forget that you were,
like, a super stud
in the NFL for a long time.
- Yeah. Well, my
favorite question to fans
that say they're real fans is,
"Who's the leading rusher
for the L.A. Rams?"
- Right.
- Most people say Eric Dickerson.
It's like, well
you don't know your history.
You didn't watch me, obviously.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- And that's the
frustrating part, is, you know
I understand
that team leadership
and team wins come together.
And I just wasn't a part
of that team.
- Right.
- But when you talk about
individual and what a person
put out on the field
what we worked hard to do?
- Yeah.
- I just want
some acknowledgement.
And sometimes I feel like
I get skipped over
and it's not because
of my talent.
I know that.
It's just because
I just had a bad break, man.
- Yeah, yeah that's what happens.
- Well, we talk about it
all the time.
It's everyone says
that wins isn't a statistic.
But yet, we treat it like
it's the greatest statistic
of all time.
- You're right. Yeah.
- That's kinda how it goes.
But what's funny is,
is then you go to the Patriots
which, there's nothing better
than Bill Belichick with a guy
that hasn't been getting respect
from another team.
Happened with Corey Dillon.
It happened with
you know, like, every safety,
wide receivers.
Happened with Chad Johnson,
our friend.
You go there.
What was your first meeting
with Belichick?
Like, what were your—
what was a great
Belichick story
about who he really is?
- My story of Belichick
is he calls me in December
LeGarrette Blount goes down,
he gets hurt.
- That was the injury.
He goes down, and I'm retired
at this point in my head.
And it's Belichick.
You know that voice.
It's very distinct.
And he goes, "Steven—"
- "Hi, Steven."
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
He goes, "Steven, uh, I got
a question for you.
Do you wanna play
football again?"
And I'm like, in my head
like, "Of course I do."
- Yeah.
- But I'm like,
they're in December.
This is the
New England Patriots
and I'm a man of pride.
I don't wanna look bad.
Like, the—my last carry
I felt I still
looked like myself.
I didn't wanna get
to New England
and look like a shell of myself.
- Yeah.
- And then people are like
"Oh, he's—"
you know, "He's terrible.
He's trash."
- Yeah, yeah.
- So I was more nervous
about public opinion
about what I would look like.
- Mmm.
- So I said, "Coach, you give me
two weeks to get in shape,
I'll come."
What was it
like going there
seeing their day-to-day
preparation
and specifically, like,
AFC Championship
getting ready for the Broncos
that year
what that was like being a part
of that organization
during that time?
- So, when you get there,
you realize that there's
no place like it in the NFL,
at least my stops.
- Yep.
There's not a lot of pictures
in the hallways.
There's not a lot of
"me, me, me," you know?
But what I found
the most interesting
to your question, is getting
ready for that AFC game
against the Denver Broncos,
if I recall right
he asked me to talk to the team.
And he wanted me to talk to them
about my NFL experience.
I'm like, "What do I have
to teach these guys," you know?
You guys have been to now eight
consecutive AFC championships.
- Right.
- Gronkowski's laughing.
He goes, "I've never
had not a bye," right?
- Right.
- I'm like, I've only been
in the playoffs twice,
first year and last year.
- Yeah.
- And he's laughing like
"You got a bad break."
- Right.
- So he asked me to talk
about my plight
so I'm telling the team
about my story.
And my story goes,
there's a part of my career
where I won six games
in three years.
- Wow.
I'm talking to the team
about me winning six games
in three years.
- Yeah.
- And you could just hear
a pin drop.
And they just couldn't believe
the amount
of eight consecutive
1,000 yards rushing
but the lack of wins
to go with it.
It's almost like those guys
wanted to win that game for me.
- Yeah.
- And that was a special moment
because I didn't think
my story was anything.
I thought I was just privileged
to be there.
But to see that it was twofold,
and that they wanted me
to kinda cap off
my career with a win.
- Sure.
- It meant a lot to me
and, you know,
I'll always forever be grateful.
- And you got a touchdown in the
AFC Championship Game in Denver.
- Yeah.
- Do you think he was
trying to, like
you know, Belichick,
like, is he trying to show, like
"Hey, you guys are spoiled."
- Absolutely he was.
- "And look how grateful
this—." Yeah, OK.
- You can't take it
for granted, right?
- Right, right.
- And I think, if you're
Gronkowski, for example,
he doesn't know anything else.
- Yeah.
- He only knows Brady, Belichick
and playoff wins,
you know what I'm saying?
- He assumes that Cincinnati's
like that.
- Yeah.
- Now they're in
a similar situation.
They haven't been
in that situation
since your speech and that game
of a road AFC Championship Game.
And since 2004, they've been to
the playoffs, like, 13 times.
This has only happened three
times, and the Patriots are 0-3.
- 0-3 on the road.
- I'm curious
what is Belichick like the week
of an AFC Championship Game?
- Very relaxed. Everyone—
- Really?
- And I would say the whole team.
That's the, that was the other
thing that was impressive.
From the running back coach
to the special teams coach
to even just
the team chaplain, it is—
- Nothing's different.
- Nothing's different there.
It is normal.
Football in January and February
is normal to them.
- It's the regular season.
- Sounds like you were
in a bizarro world—
- I was.
- Where you're like,
"I've never been here before.
This is insane." And everyone's
like, "It's Tuesday, Steven.
Take a seat."
- Yeah, I'm normally
looking at my passport.
I'm in Costa Rica
somewhere, right?
- Yeah.
- And they're like, "Nah, man.
This is divisional round week."
- My only other thing is
if you could say anything to
the basketball Stephen Jackson
what would you say to him?
- Stak5, what's up?
- Do you guys, like, talk?
Do the Steven Jacksons
talk to each other?
- No, we haven't talked in a while.
We've, we ran into
each other before.
Um, oddly enough,
it was in a nightclub
in San Antonio and I—
we got each other's bills.
- Really? That's how you—
Did you even—
- You don't wanna mess with
that NBA money, man.
- Yeah, yeah.
I'm like, no, no, no.
I'm not guaranteed.
I'll take the small one.
- I didn't order three
Ace of Spades.
- Right.
So there's been some mixups.
- That's unbelievable.
I love it.
We're happy to have you, man.
- Thank you, man.
- Yeah, thanks for coming by.
- For real.
- Seriously.
- Hi, I'm LaMarr Woodley.
And you're watching
"Simms & Lefkoe."
Let's go.
Lefkoe?
Let's go, all the same.
Just let's go.
- What do ya know?
Lefkoe's Locks have been
hittin' in the playoffs.
I haven't needed anybody,
let alone somebody.
7-1, and for the season,
I'm 34-34-3.
Oooh, .500 feels good.
No thanks to Allie.
He's 0-2 in the playoffs
and you know I'm lettin' him
hear about it.
This man is 0-2 in the playoffs.
He's gone from Allie the Oracle
to Allie the Mush.
And I'm 7-1 against the spread
in the playoffs, Allie.
I'm open for advice
if you need it.
- Your team is out of it, though.
- Why—?
- So 7-1 means nothing.
- It means a lot to my ego.
Chiefs are favored by three at home
against the Patriots.
- Chiefs-Patriots,
I don't have a pick.
I need some,
I need some help with this one.
- Timeout.
- I need a little bit of help.
- Are you asking for
a little Lefkoe guidance?
- Little bit.
- Cuz it would be my pleasure.
I'm leaning Chiefs.
- OK.
- But it's tough for me
to go against Tom Brady.
What do you think?
- My thing is, is that Tom
doesn't have to play
in the championship games
on the road often.
He's only had three road games
since 2004.
Broncos, Steelers, Colts,
I believe.
And he's lost all three of them.
I would go Chiefs
because I think
it's Patrick Mahomes at home.
I don't know.
I love that kid.
I feel the magic.
- Patrick Mahomes at home.
Arrowhead, Arrowhead.
The first game
was in Foxborough.
- Yes.
- Chiefs.
- Did you see that?
Did you see his eyes?
- Gotta go Chiefs. Gotta go Chiefs.
- He White Walker-ed.
He went, "Chiefs."
- Chiefs.
I'm gonna let you know now
though, if Tom Brady wins—
- New England
with the Super Bowl.
You don't even have to come.
Lettin' you know now.
- Wow.
I felt Oracle emanation
right there.
That was really serious.
- Sounds crazy.
I'm goin' against them
this week, but if they win
I'm goin' with them
to the Super Bowl.
- Typical Allie hedging.
What a mush.
What a mush, this guy.
- It's all right.
Don't worry.
We'll be fine.
- So Allie finally comes
to his senses
listens to what I have to say
and he's takin'
the Chiefs minus-3.
- OK.
- Gonna be honest
Three is a lot of points.
I'm gonna wait until Patriots
bettors knock it down
and then I'm gonna bet
on the Chiefs.
- Yeah, I hear that.
- But you think the Chiefs
are gonna win.
- I do think
the Chiefs are gonna win.
I mean, both of these games
should be really close.
- It's so dumb, betting
against the Patriots.
- I know. But I do.
If you made me bet on this game
I would take the Chiefs.
Maybe to win
a four-point game, 34-30.
- OK.
- 35-31, something like that.
- So you see high scoring.
- Yeah, somewhere along there.
- Both games are rematches
of amazing regular-season games.
In those two games,
over 160 points scored.
But I don't think it's gonna be
the same game
and I know
that you definitely don't.
- No.
- So, Saints-Rams.
- Yes.
- What's gonna be different about
that game from the first match?
- Well, I think the first thing
that jumps out
to me is one stat line
with Michael Thomas
12 receptions, 211 yards, right?
Had the unbelievable
performance
burned Marcus Peters in one of
the biggest plays of the game.
Sean Payton said
they liked the matchup.
We're gonna see
that little rivalry flamed up.
- Talib didn't play in that game.
- Talib did not play.
And the other big point,
Lefkoe, is this.
The Rams don't play those style
of defenses anymore.
They are not really a matchup,
man-to-man defense
like they were back in Week 11.
Now they have really become
more of a zone team.
We're gonna play sound coverages
in the back end
let our front four
get after the quarterback.
- Sure.
- So, hey, Michael Thomas
he's extremely hard to defend.
We know that not only
because he's a good player
but Sean Payton
moves him around everywhere.
- You know what else, though?
- So I think he could be around
100 yards,
but no way around 200 yards.
- That was also the
Sheldon Rankins breakout game.
- It was.
- He won't play in this game.
- He's not there, right.
- So that's big, too.
- Crazy stat about that game?
No sacks, right?
Can you believe that,
in that type of game?
- That's not happening again.
- That's insane.
No, I would not say
that happens again.
- What happened
in Chiefs-Patriots
during the regular season
that's definitely
not happening on Sunday?
- I think the big thing
to look at there is
there was 13 total rush attempts
by the Kansas City Chiefs
running backs
in that football game.
- That's Andy Reid, man.
- Yes, that's Andy Reid.
We know that.
So why I say
that won't happen again
the first reason is this.
The Chiefs have been trying
to be a more balanced team.
We saw that last week
against the Colts.
Damien Williams had some success
running between the tackles.
So I think they've been
underneath the center
with Patrick Mahomes.
- Yeah.
- The attempts are very important
because when you become
one-dimensional against
Bill Belichick and company,
you're in deep trouble.
If they can just go,
"Oh, you're gonna throw
the ball every down"
they're gonna come up with
a million different coverages
to confuse Mahomes,
doubles, blitzes
everything under the moon, OK?
So the big thing there
would be the attempts
because it keeps
the Patriots defense honest.
And then with Mahomes
under center
one of the great things
about being under center
and running the ball
is the play-action passes.
And we've seen that a little
more from them as of late, too
to get Tyreek down the field,
Kelce down the field.
But can Andy Reid do it?
Will he stay with it?
Because you know
as an Eagles fan
he loves to throw the ball.
But when they played in the
Super Bowl, Patriots-Eagles,
he threw the ball
50-plus-something times.
- Yes.
- He does that again
they're in trouble.
Or if they rush the ball
for 13 attempts or less
that means they got down early
and had to throw
and they're in trouble anyways.
That would be my two cents.
- Your analysis is fine.
- Oh, thanks.
- But something is happening
Sunday night that scares me
and I don't know
what it means yet.
- Yeah.
- Apparently, it's gonna happen
during the Chiefs-Patriots game
over Arrowhead.
- Yep.
- A super blood wolf moon—
- And with the arctic blast.
- Is happening
during the game.
- Yes.
- I don't know if this is going
to be Belichick
using the universe
to suck the powers
out of Patrick Mahomes
and giving 'em to Brady for
another 20 years of his career
or if this is
the sign of the end
and the birth of a new
blood king in Patrick Mahomes
to reign over the NFL
and we are all powerless
to his majesty.
- I mean, red moon over
Kansas City would mean
I would think,
powers to Kansas City.
Your analysis was fine there
as well.
- Thanks.
Just saying, if you see
Belichick start itching his neck
and start crawling
on all fours
run, because it could
get dicey. For Simms.
- Peace out, homies.
- I am the L-E-F-K-O-E.
- Man.
- And we will holla, holla, holla
atcha later.
Enjoy the super red bull
wolf moon vampire—
- What? Just enjoy the games!
They're gonna be awesome.
- Vampire killer.
♪♪♪
- Before we start, is that
Saquon Barkley's thighs?
- Yes.
- Holy s--t.
- Are we recording? I hope we're recording.
- Are you saying "holy s--t"
or that that's what his legs look like?
- No, they're unreal, right?
- That's like Jamal Anderson,
right?
- You're right.
It is.
- The running back.
- Yeah.
- You just don't see
that kind of, like,
that's just not everyday.
- Jamal Anderson,
Michael Turner, right?
- That's why we have that up there.
- Michael Turner, yeah, yeah.
- It's a fire hydrant leg.
- It's a fire hydrant.
- Yes.